[Musik]
herzlich Willkommen zu ZDF heute live es
ist Tag 9 des russischen angriffskriegs
gegen die Ukraine hunderttausende
Ukraine 100.000 Menschen sind bereits
geflohen nach Polen nach Ungarn in die
Slowakei nach Rumänien aber wie geht es
den Menschen in der Ukraine denen die
seit neun Tagen in Bunkern in Kellern
teilweise in Metrostationen sitzen vor
wenigen Stunden erklärte der
Bürgermeister aus Mario Paul die
Hafenstadt im Südosten des Landes liege
unter Feuer und brauche militärische
Unterstützung es gäbe keine
Wasserversorgung keine Fernheizung oder
Stromversorgung mehr und auch die
Lebensmittelvorräte gingen zur Neige wie
geht es den Menschen dort und auch in
anderen großen Städten welche Hilfe
brauchen sie erreicht sie überhaupt noch
Hilfe und was können die
Hilfsorganisationen tun angesichts der
Angriffe darüber wollen wir heute
sprechen zum einen mit Michaela Bauer
der stellvertretenden Leiterin der
Mission in der Ukraine mit Anna
kolomitsawa einer ukrainischen
Dolmetscherin die sehr gut Deutsch
spricht und in hakif einer stark
umkämpften Stadt lebt und mit unserem
zDF-Reporter Armin Körper der bereits
berichtet hat über die Hilfe die in
Lemberg ganz im Westen der Ukraine
organisiert wird bevor wir aber in die
Ukraine Schalten mit ihnen reden und
direkt erfahren wie die Lage ist ein
Überblick über das was heute in der
Ukraine geschehen ist
die Hölle des Krieges erreicht Kiew
Bilder aus costume einer Siedlung direkt
am Stadtrand ein Video der ukrainischen
Seite das russische Verluste zeigen soll
beim versuchen die Hauptstadt vor
zurückrücken heute Russen haben ein Ziel
das ist Hauptstadt und die Hauptstadt
hat eine symbolische Bedeutung das ist
die Hauptstadt von Türkei
und das ist Herzdruck eine und deswegen
die Russen versuchen jetzt das ist die
Kreis um zu machen sie wollen ihre Stadt
verteidigen freiwillige errichten an
vielen Stellen in Kiew Panzersperren und
Barrikaden wird das reichen den Gegner
aufzuhalten
ich weiß nicht ob das klappt ich bin
kein general wir werden es versuchen
deshalb sind wir hier
andere suchen ja Heil in der Flucht zu
groß sind die Ungewissheit und die Angst
vor dem was nun kommen wird
die große Frage die wir nicht
beantworten können
wird die russische Armee versuchen Kiew
in Anführungszeichen auszuhungern oder
wird man den Strom auf Kiew vorbereiten
das heißt Häuserkampf letzteres würde zu
einem unglaublichen Blutbad in dieser
Stadt führen Tag acht des Einmarsches
bringt kaum russische Geländegewinne
neben Kiew stehen Harke für Mittelpunkt
und das eingeschlossene Mario Pohl aus
dem es heute keine Bilder gibt die
Millionenstadt Harke fliegt weiter unter
Beschuss im Norden der Stadt schlagen
fast stündlich Raketen und Granaten ein
zur Augenzahl in Lemberg in der
Westukraine berühmt für seinen
Weltkulturerbe haben sie begonnen
wichtige Statuen und andere Kulturgüter
zu verpacken und vor dem Krieg in
Sicherheit zu bringen
nicht nur die Erwachsenen leiden in der
Ukraine Leben 7,5 Millionen Kinder und
viele von ihnen haben durch die Angriffe
ihr Zuhause verloren oder sind auf der
Flucht und zugeschaltet aus Lemberg ist
jetzt Michaela Bauer die
stellvertretende Leiterin der UNICEF
hilfs für Kinderhilfswerk Mission in der
Ukraine Frau Bauer bis vor wenigen Tagen
sind sie in Kiew gewesen da ist das Büro
von UNICEF Ukraine aber es ist zu
gefährlich geworden und sie haben das
Büro verlegen müssen
ja die Sicherheitslage hat sich
drastisch verändert im Laufe der letzten
Woche aber natürlich auch die
Versorgungslage und damit auch unsere
Möglichkeit unsere Arbeit zu tun und
deswegen haben wir zumindest einen Teil
unserer Mitarbeiter in den Westen des
Landes verlagert aber auch weil im
Westen des Landes natürlich jetzt
größere Hilfslieferungen ankommen die
wir versuchen dann ins Zentrum und in
den Osten des Landes zu bringen wo die
Hilfe am meisten benötigte
aber beschreiben Sie einfach ein
bisschen wie ist denn die Lage in Kiew
und was haben Sie auch auf der Fahrt von
Kiew nach Lemberg erlebt wir sehen ja
immer wieder Bilder wie
familienkinder in Metrostationen
aushalten wir haben gerade wieder Bilder
gesehen Angriffe etc diese riesige
Kolonne die auf Kiew zu holt wie ist die
Situation in Kiew
ja die Situation in Kiew ist sehr
angespannt es variiert von Tag zu Tag
ein bisschen aber die Menschen kommen
und vor allem die Kinder kommen eben
nicht zur Ruhe es gibt ständige
Geschütze die Menschen müssen sich
verstecken den Bunkern die Kinder haben
oft tagelang mit ihren Eltern zusammen
dort aus und haben Angst und ja auf der
Fahrt haben wir einfach gesehen wie sich
das Land verändert hat innerhalb von
einer Woche es gibt kaum mehr Kinder die
man sieht die Spielplätze sind leer die
Schulen sind leer es gibt viele
Militärstützpunkte und die Menschen
haben Schwierigkeiten vom einen an den
anderen Ort sich weiter zu bewegen und
ja die Lage ist so kritisch in manchen
Orten dass es keine
Nahrungsmittelversorgung gibt dass die
Trinkwasserversorgung in manchen Teilen
des Ostens komplett zusammengebrochen
ist so wie sie es auch in mariopol
gesehen haben
jetzt noch mal die Frage wie muss ich
mir das vorstellen fährt man setzt man
sich einfach in Kiew ins Auto und guckt
a von Norden kommen die Truppen wir
fahren nach Süden raus und biegt dann ab
irgendwo ein Schild steht Richtung
Lemberg wie gefährlich ist die Fahrt
gewesen haben sie da auch
Truppenbewegungen etc gesehen
ja man sieht Truppenbewegungen überall
im Land und ungefährlich sind Bewegungen
momentan nicht aber als UN-Organisation
müssen wir dann natürlich auch ganz
spezielle
Regeln einhalten wenn wir uns weiter
bewegen aber es geht sozusagen nicht um
uns und unsere Bewegungen sondern ist
man sieht vor allem auf der Straße die
Bewegung der Menschen es sind Familien
die auseinandergerissen sind vor allem
Frauen und Kinder die sich in Richtung
Westen bewegen und die sich über die
Grenzen bewegen das haben sie ja auch in
ihren Beiträgen schon gezeigt und deren
deren Situation ist sehr kritisch die
können sich nicht immer auf auf auf die
Versorgung verlassen die denen Mangels
an Bargeld weil auch das schwierig zu
erreichen ist es mangelt an an Benzin an
den Tankstellen und die Lage ist
insgesamt so dass Kinder ein normales
Leben momentan in der Ukraine nur sehr
schwer leben können
wir haben es eben schon gesagt der
Bürgermeister von mariopol sagt es gibt
keinen Strom keine Heizung keine
Wasserversorgung nichts mehr die
Nahrungsmittel werden knapp mariopol am
Schwarzen Meer gelegen wird von zwei
Seiten eingekesselt wie ist denn die
Versorgungslage in Kiew gibt es da noch
Wasser Strom oder wird das auch knapp
es gibt uns das Wissens schon noch
Wasser und Strom aber die
Versorgungslage in den Supermärkten war
teilweise sehr angespannt ich so viel
ich weiß ist es in den letzten beiden
Tagen ein bisschen besser geworden aber
was wir wirklich jetzt brauchen und das
setzt sich die UNICEF zusammen mit
anderen Organisationen dafür einen sind
grüne sogenannte grüne Korridore
humanitäre Korridore die die Hilfsgüter
an die
umzingelten Orte bringen kann und zu den
Menschen bringen kann
sie haben die Korridore angesprochen da
gab es gestern Verhandlungen die zweite
Verhandlungsrunde die hat keinen Frieden
keine Waffenruhe gebracht aber genau das
wurde da besprochen humanitäre Korridore
damit Zivilisten evakuiert werden können
da muss ich aber dann sie fragen sie
haben ja sehr sehr viel Erfahrung wie
für wie realistisch halten sie das dass
diese Korridore tatsächlich
geschaffen werden dass man sich da auch
ja sicher bewegen kann eine Stadt
verlassen kann und nicht doch unter
Beschuss gerät
ja es gibt es gibt jetzt jede Menge
Bemühungen diese diese Bestreben die
humanitären Korridore durchzusetzen auch
umzusetzen das dauert natürlich noch
vermutlich ein paar Tage dauern aber wir
bereiten uns für diesen Moment vor wir
haben die ersten Hilfslieferungen jetzt
die ins Land gekommen sind heute im
Laufe des Tages und in den nächsten
Tagen und unsere große Priorität in den
nächsten Tagen wird sein vor allem
medizinische Hilfsgüter zu den
Krankenhäusern zu bringen vor allem
Kinderkrankenhäuser im ganzen Land die
schon seit Tagen sehr an an den Grenzen
ihres möglichen operieren aber auch
andere Hilfsmöglichkeiten die
Wasserversorgung habe ich schon erwähnt
aber auch die psychosoziale Betreuung
von Kindern und Familien ist sehr
wichtig und zum Beispiel auch ganz
normale
Möglichkeiten Kindern wieder ein
bisschen Alltag zu geben zum Beispiel
durch
nothilfe-kits die ihnen das Spielen
wieder erlauben die in das Lernen wieder
erlauben
ja aber da muss ich sie ganz einfach
fragen wie kann das funktionieren das
hört sich ja prima an und optimistisch
dass man diesen Kindern ein bisschen
Normalität geben kann aber beschreiben
Sie einfach mal was macht das denn mit
den Kindern wir sehen ja immer wieder
die Bilder wenn auf einmal Sirenen
heulen Luftangriffe sind und die Mutter
oder die Oma die Kinder packt und in den
Keller Rennen diese Bilder sehen wir
immer wieder und was macht das mit den
Kindern
die Kinder sind verstört die Kinder
wissen die neue Realität nur sehr schwer
einzuschätzen und sie werden
traumatisiert und sie brauchen dringend
Hilfe um mit dieser neuen Realität
umzugehen und ein Teil des ein Teil
dieser Hilfe kann eben sein zumindest
ein bisschen Normalität wieder
herzustellen aber ohne eine dauerhafte
Waffenruhe ist wird es nur sehr
schmutzig schwer möglich sein aber es
gibt viele an starke
Nichtregierungsorganisationen im Lande
die auch auf Gemeindeebene arbeiten und
wir arbeiten sehr eng mit diesen
Organisationen zusammen und auch mit dem
Gemeinden um zumindest zu versuchen mal
wieder ein bisschen Normalität in den
Alltag der Kinder zu bringen
ein bisschen Normalität wir haben auch
Bilder gesehen die eben alles andere als
normal sind dass Männer Väter sich
verabschieden von ihren Familien und
sagen ich muss an die Front ich muss
kämpfen einerseits wenn die Familien mit
Zügen in den Westen in die Sicherheit
fahren die Männer bleiben zurück
was kann man denn einem Kind sagen wenn
der Vater auf einmal weg ist
ja es ist sehr schwierig sie sprechen da
eine ganz neue Realität an die viele
Familien in der Ukraine zum ersten Mal
erleben und ich sehe das bei meinen
eigenen Kollegen die die plötzlich davon
betroffen sind dass die Väter
zurückbleiben müssen und die Kinder und
und Mütter sich in Richtung Sicherheit
bewegen man kann den Kindern nur
versuchen
von einer Zukunft zu erzählen in der die
Situation sich verbessert und auch an
der Zukunft in in der Frieden möglich
ist und deswegen appellieren wir an
beide Parteien dieses Konfliktes diese
Waffenruhe und zumindest auch die Grünen
Korridore herzustellen damit wir ein
bisschen mehr in diese Richtung arbeiten
können der Kinder wieder eine normale
Kindheit erleben können
die Frage was brauchen die Kinder am
meisten brauche ich glaube ich gar nicht
stellen sie ergibt sich von selbst sie
haben es gerade gesagt eine Waffenruhe
einfach Frieden aber wie weit ist man
davon weg das sind politische Fragen die
wir nicht beantworten können aber wir
kriegen ja mit wir haben ja eben auch
den Bericht gesehen dass er auch immer
mehr Städte mariopol ja geradezu
umzingelt werden und da stellt sich dann
eben die Frage wie kann denn dann
überhaupt noch geholfen werden kann denn
da überhaupt noch Hilfe reinkommen sie
sagten ja gerade wir versorgen eben auch
Krankenhäuser etc ist dann da auch
irgendwann Feierabend
es geht jetzt darum die Zivilisten die
belagerte Städte verlassen wollen dass
die die Möglichkeit sie haben sie zu
verlassen und das gleichzeitig haben die
Korridore geöffnet werden um
Hilfslieferungen in diese Städte zu
bringen und die und und gleichzeitig
auch zu versuchen die Dienstleistungen
die jetzt zum großen Teil nicht mehr
möglich sind im Bereich Gesundheit
Bildung Wasserversorgung die wieder
einigermaßen herzustellen aber es wird
natürlich lange dauern um um ein eine
Normalität wieder herzustellen vor allem
in den Städten die in den letzten Tagen
unter Belagerung stand
wir haben jetzt gerade eben angesprochen
noch mal die Frage dann wie sieht denn
die Lage in Kiew aus was die
Krankenhäuser angeht wenn sie sagen das
ist ja auch teilweise schwierig die
Krankenhäuser zu versorgen
ja die den Krankenhäuser fehlt fehlt es
jetzt schon an an vielen wir haben mit
ein paar freiwilligen versucht zumindest
ein paar Hilfsgüter zu ihnen zu bringen
und haben jetzt vor allem in den
nächsten Tagen vor nach Kiew und auch in
andere Länder in andere Städte wie wie
ich Harke und
im Osten des Landes wieder Krankenhäuser
zu versorgen aber es ist schwierig weil
auch die logistischen Möglichkeiten
beschränkt sind aber wir werden es
nichts unversuch lassen um die
Hilfsgüter die jetzt ins Land kommen
auch dorthin zu bringen wo sie am
meisten benötigt werden
völlig klar dass sie da einen
wahnsinnigen Job machen weil diese
Hilfsgüter benötigt werden aber
gleichzeitig stellen wir vor ich müsste
jetzt Hilfsgüter nach Harke fahren ist
das nicht irgendwie doch
lebensgefährlich wenn der Norden der
Stadt beschossen wird und man muss
irgendwie versuchen von Süden
reinzukommen
darum brauchen wir eben die Feuerpause
damit die Güter sicher dorthin
transportiert werden können wo die
Menschen sie am meisten brauchen
denn zum Abschluss die Frage die sich
wahrscheinlich viele Stellen wie können
denn die Menschen in Deutschland die den
Menschen in der Ukraine Flüchtenden den
Familien vor allen Dingen eben auch den
Kindern helfen wollen die Ihnen helfen
wollen damit sie weiterhelfen können was
können die Menschen denn in Deutschland
am besten machen wie kann man am besten
helfen
die Menschen können sich weiterhin für
Frieden einsetzen das haben sie in
Deutschland sehr lautstark getan und das
das tut auch den Menschen hier gut zu
sehen dass das der Rest der Welt auf
ihrer Seite steht und die Menschen
können sich weiterhin dafür einsetzen
das Spendengelder dorthin kommen wo sie
am meisten gebraucht werden flexible
Spenden sind am meisten gebraucht
momentan weiß ich die Lage eben auch von
Tag zu Tag verändert und weil es nicht
nur um Sachgüter geht sondern auch um
Unterstützung wie zum Beispiel
psychosoziale Betreuung aber auch um die
Wasserversorgung wieder herzustellen da
wo sie unterbrochen ist
da wollen wir an dieser Stelle diese
Möglichkeit noch mal aufzeigen fast 52
Millionen Euro sind bereits
zusammengekommen für das Aktionsbündnis
Katastrophenhilfe wo sie eben auch ein
wichtiger Teil sind und wenn man den
Menschen in der Ukraine und jeden auf
der Flucht eben helfen will dann kann
man das weiterhin tun einfach mit der
IBAN
de65/100 400
400 600 Stichwort ZDF Nothilfe Ukraine
alle Infos haben wir auch unter
spenden.zdf.de oder im zdf-text auf
Seite 890 dann haben wir diese
Möglichkeit auch klar aufgezeigt und
Frau Bauer recht herzlichen Dank und
weiterhin alles alles Gute und vor allen
Dingen gute Arbeit jetzt von Lemberg aus
wo sie die Hilfe weiter koordinieren
wollen alles Gute
den herzlichen Dank
wir schauen jetzt weiter nach harkev in
Nordosten des Landes Rakes 1,5 Millionen
Einwohner ist nach Kiew die zweitgrößte
Stadt der Ukraine mit vielen
Fachhochschulen Universitäten einem
pulsierenden Leben aber seit Tagen ist
hakiff unter Beschuss Rücken russische
Truppen von Norden auf die Großstadt zu
werden Wohnviertel von Raketen getroffen
in hakif lebt Anna Kolo miceva eine
ukrainische Dolmetscherin easy ist in
der Stadt zu ihren Eltern geflüchtet
weil es dort sicherer ist um ein
Interview über Skype mit uns zu machen
musste sie aber in ihre Wohnung zurück
um das Internet eben da zu nutzen und
weil es meistens morgens etwas ruhiger
ist wie sie sagte und weniger Beschuss
weniger Raketenangriffe gibt hat sie
darum gebeten dieses Interview doch am
Vormittag zu machen und aus
Sicherheitsgründen haben wir das
Interview das Gespräch mit ihr heute
Vormittag am Morgen also bezeichnen und
dieses Interview ist aber eben für Anna
sehr sehr wichtig denn das hat sie uns
gesagt sie möchte der Welt erzählen wie
die Wahrheit ist
Frau koloniezimmer erstmal vielen Dank
dass wir mit Ihnen reden können die
erste wichtige Frage wie geht es Ihnen
wie ist die Situation in rakif
mir geht persönlich geht es mir mehr
oder weniger gut das heißt ich bin
gesund und in Ordnung ich bekomme
regelmäßig Trinkwasser was zu essen und
ich
befinde mich in einer warmen Wohnung und
meine Familie ist auch in meiner Seite
und es geht meiner Familie auch gut
ansonsten ist die Situation natürlich
schrecklich
kurz gefasst seit einer Woche steht
meine Heimatstadt hakif unter sehr
starken Bombardierung das heißt es
fliegen Bomben aller Art auf meine Stadt
das ist Kurzversion von von dem wie es
aussieht wir hören jetzt wir lesen in
Agenturen dass gestern mindestens 34
Zivilisten getötet und Hunderte verletzt
worden sein sollen in Rakels was hören
sie von Bekannten von Freunden sie leben
ja im Südteil von hakif andere
vielleicht im Nordteil was vielleicht
noch mehr beschossen wird was kriegen
sie damit
zum Glück gibt es unter meinen Freunden
Angehörigen jetzt keine Opfer von diesen
Konflikt und hoffentlich wird es auch in
der Zukunft keinen geben aber es gibt
natürlich
Stadtbezirke die gefährlicher sind als
andere aber man kann nie raten welcher
Stadtbezirk der nächste sein soll das
heißt die Stadt Hagen sie liegt dann
eine an der Grenze mit Russland das
heißt die Grenze verläuft nördlicher von
der Stadt und es ist natürlich dass der
Angriff auch vom Norden kommt und so ist
es auch geschehen das heißt die Menschen
die im nördlichen Teil der Stadt wohnen
den geht es am schlechtesten und die
Bomben die Fliegen direkt in die
Wohnhäuser also von den Russen kann man
jetzt von offiziellen also Politikern in
offiziellen Berichten kann man hören
lesen dass die nur militärobjekte
beschießen das stimmt nicht die
beschießen Zivilisten sie beschießen
Wohnhäuser da gibt es in der Nähe so gut
wie keine
militärobjekte sie fielen direkt auf die
Zivilbevölkerung und auf die ganz
normalen Wohnhäuser
sie sagen die russischen Truppen nähern
sich von Norden sie wurden noch im
Südtal der Stadt haben Sie Angst das
rakif in vielleicht wenigen Tagen
umzingelt ist und sie auch wenn sie
wollten gar nicht mehr fliehen könnten
diese Gefahr die besteht aber ich
glaube gar nicht dass die Stadt sich
aufgibt
insbesondere nach den neuesten
Ereignissen von der letzten Woche die
Menschen
also die Stimmung in der Stadt ist
überhaupt sie geht in überhaupt eine
andere Richtung also direkt an das hier
rum die Menschen wollen bis zum zum
letzten
[Musik]
Irland schützen und selbst wenn die
Stadt umzingelt wird
glaube ich nicht dass die Stadt auch
gibt
die sie haben ja selbst gerade
beschrieben sie haben noch eine warme
Wohnung sie haben Lebensmittel und
Wasser wir kriegen aber ja auch Berichte
aus anderen Ecken der Ukraine vor allen
Dingen aus dem Osten wo Menschen seit
Tagen mehrere Tage lang keinen Strom
haben keine Verpflegung haben seit Tagen
in Bunkern sitzen eben auch aus
Großstädten wo der Strom ausgefallen ist
etc wie sieht die Versorgungslage aus
ist das auch zu befürchten oder kommen
noch Lebensmittel eben nach hakelfreien
es gibt Lebensmittel also ich als eine
ganz normale Bürgerin ich habe
vielleicht nicht die ganze Informationen
über die Versorgung der Stadt aber so
gut wie ich informiert bin kann ich
Ihnen sagen dass es eine zentrale für
versorgungsfragen von der von dem
Bürgermeister geschafft worden ist und
die Behörden sie kümmern sich um die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger der Stadt und das
kann ich auch selbst erleben das heißt
heute morgen konnte man Fleisch besorgen
und Milchprodukte
was auch nicht schlecht ist für die
Situation würde ich sagen das heißt
für die Versorgung der Bürgerinnen und
Bürger getragen
jetzt ist harkef ja man muss sich das
immer noch mal vor Augen halten ganz im
Nordosten der Ukraine nicht wie Lemberg
nah im Westen und damit nah an der
polnischen Grenze das heißt also Haken
ist ja sie sind ja ganz weit weg von der
Grenze zu Polen zur Slowakei zu Ungarn
Rumänien etc wenn der Westen sagt wir
wollen die Ukraine unterstützen kann
denn überhaupt Hilfe aus dem Westen sei
es eben Nahrung sonstige Hilfsgüter
überhaupt hakif erreichen
also hoffentlich im Moment werden diese
humanitären Fragen
immer wichtiger und immer krasser das
heißt es gibt sehr viele Ehrenamtliche
hier vor Ort die sich dafür kümmern dass
die Versorgung immer noch
gewährleistet wird und humanitäre Hilfe
gibt es auch von von vielen Seiten aus
unterschiedlichen Länder der Welt und
unterschiedlichsten Länder Europas und
ich glaube es gibt Menschen die dafür
wiederum Sorge tragen würden dass diese
Hilfe erreicht wir hören auch dass eben
viele Ukraine Freunde in Russland
anrufen um gerade den Menschen in
Russland zu erzählen wie die Lage
tatsächlich ist glaubt nicht den
Staatsmedien die von einer
spezialoperation sprechen von einer
friedensoperation also das narrativ die
Geschichten von Putin wiederholen machen
sie das gleiche ist das so dass Freunde
versuchen irgendwie auch in Russland die
wahr komplett dahin zu transportieren
ja das stimmt also Sie haben Recht
die Menschen versuchen das zu machen in
sozialen Medien und persönlich Telefon
und so gut wie es geht aber
diese Versuche sie sind mehr oder
weniger vergeblich das heißt die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger in Russlands die
hören auf uns nicht
es gibt trotzdem Menschen in Russland
die auch von alleine verstehen also ohne
dass wir auch sie reden sie verstehen
von alleine das ist ein Krieg ist und
das ist schrecklich ist und kleine
Militäroperation und so und so weiter
aber
diejenigen die schon feste Überzeugung
haben dass es sich um eine
Militäroperation handelt und und und
die kann man sehr schwer überzeugen dass
es eigentlich nicht so ist
welche Hoffnung haben Sie denn dann noch
sie sind jetzt keine
militärexpertin keine
Verteidigungsministerin aber ich frage
Sie ganz einfach als jemand der in
haakev sitzt und das alles miterlebt
welche Hoffnung haben Sie denn dass
dieser Krieg irgendwie noch gestoppt
wird oder haben Sie irgendeine
Vorstellung wie ist es das setzen Sie
auf die Menschen in Russland dass sie
sozusagen auf die Straße gehen das Putin
dort von den eigenen Menschen gestoppt
wird oder welche Möglichkeiten welche
Hoffnungen haben quasi sie
die Hoffnung die ich hege ist eigentlich
die das unsere Stadt also ich meine die
Architektur die
Infrastruktur der Stadt dass sie mehr
oder weniger bleibt aber wenn auch das
nicht der Fall sein soll glaube ich
zumindest oder hoffe ich zumindest dass
es
so gut wie es geht wenige Menschen
verletzt oder getötet werden im Laufe
von diesem Konflikt
es würde uns natürlich sehr helfen wenn
der Himmel über der Ukraine geschlossen
wäre
Joe Biden meinte das ist nicht möglich
ansonsten wird es heißen dass die USA
auch eine Partei dieses Krieges werden
aber wir brauchen das wirklich dringend
dass diese Raketen auf uns nicht mehr
fliegen das heißt es meines Wissens ist
es den Truppen in der Ukraine gelungen
die
Okkupanten zu stoppen auf der werde aber
auf der Luft ist es schwieriger das
heißt sie nutzen jede mögliche Form von
den Raketen auch diejenigen die von
internationalen Konventionen untersagt
verboten sind
und das muss gestoppt werden wenn man
muss alle Mittel dafür einsetzen dass
sie uns nicht mehr bombardieren und wenn
das
geschieht wenn das gezielt erzählt wird
dann
geht uns besser ich glaube ab sofort
also alles andere können wir meistern
auch von alleine
jetzt will ich das Aufgreifen was Sie
gesagt haben nicht die Lufthoheit wir
haben eben den Eindruck die ukrainische
Luftwaffe ist quasi ausgeschaltet worden
und sie sagen berechtigterweise wenn
eine Macht die Lufthoheit hat ist das
ein entscheidender Faktor in einem Krieg
deshalb auch eine Frage der besten sagt
sie haben es auch gesagt die NATO wird
nicht eingreifen der Westen geht aber
hin und sagte unterstützen die Ukraine
mit Waffen Panzerabwehrwaffen Boden
Luftwaffen die also dann mit denen man
Flugzeuge bekämpfen könnte egal welche
Form von Waffen vom Westen geliefert
werden haben sie den Eindruck die
erreichen die Ukraine noch rechtzeitig
oder ist das eigentlich schon zu spät
ich hoffe dass zumindest dass sie recht
zeitlich uns erreichen das hoffe ich
zumindest
man muss sich aber im Klang sein jeder
Tag der Verzögerung bedeutet
jemandes Leben und zwar Leben von
kleinen Kindern Leben von Menschen mit
Behinderung die gar nicht aus ihren
Wohnung raus können das bedeutet die
Leben von den Frauen von von Müttern
von den Verteidigern der Ukraine und das
bedeutet menschliche Leben und das ist
nicht einfach ein Tag der Verzögerung
das heißt das ist ein neuer Tag wo
Bomben fliegen und ein neuer Tag wo
Menschen sterben
insofern vielen vielen Dank für dieses
Interview gut dass wir sie erreicht
haben und wir wünschen Ihnen alles Gute
sei es bei der Hilfe jetzt für die Tiere
für die anderen Menschen vielleicht auch
die ihre Häuser im Norden verloren haben
alles alles Gute passen Sie auf sich auf
und ich hoffe wir uns bald wieder
sprechen vielen Dank
Dankeschön und alles Gute nach
soweit der Blick nach haakev soweit das
Gespräch mit Anna koloniceva wir schauen
jetzt noch einmal nach Lemberg in dem
Westen der Ukraine Lemberg ist zum
Drehkreuz geworden zum einen für die
Flüchtlinge da kommen tausende aus dem
Osten an sind froh es mit Zügen mit
Autos wie auch immer nach Lemberg in den
etwas sichereren Westen geschafft zu
haben da sind die Flüchtlinge die
gleichzeitig von Lemberg weiter nach
Westen wollen nach Polen und von dort
aus weiter gleichzeitig ist Lemberg aber
auch ein Drehkreuz für die Hilfe
geworden für die Ukraine und unser
zDF-Reporter Armin Körper hat dort
gedreht und erlebt wie gepackt und
verteilt wird Armin wie läuft das ganze
was kommt woher und was geht wohin
genau man muss sich das so vorstellen da
kommen also zum Teil sehr große
Lastwagen mit Hilfsgütern aus allen
Teilen von Europa die kommen soweit ich
das gehört habe weitestgehend über Polen
in Polen werden die umgeladen auf
kleinere LKW weil die großen
offensichtlich Schwierigkeiten haben die
Grenze zu passieren im Westen der
Ukraine hier rund um Lemberg sind
dezentrale Lager wo die von diesen
kleineren Lastwagen angefahren werden
dort wird das alles ausgeladen und wird
dann vor allem umgepackt das heißt die
reißen alles auf jeden sagt jedes Paket
jede Tüte gucken was da drin ist und
sortieren das neu also ich sag mal
salopp Windel zur Windel Wasser zu
Wasser Kosmetik zu kosmetikmedizin zu
Medizin das ist natürlich ein ziemlicher
Aufwand und die haben das komplett
dezentralisiert dass das also möglichst
viele kleine Orte sind wenn man
natürlich auch Angst hat dass solche
hilfszentren
zur zielt zum Ziel russischer
Luftangriffe werden von daher sind das
sehr viele Orte und wir wurden auch
immer wieder ermahnt dass wir weder
zeigen noch sagen dürfen wo wir da sind
und wo sich dieses Lager befindet
jetzt hast du ein paar Sachen schon
genannt Armin was kommt denn vor allem
an ist es Wasser das benötigt wird sind
das Medikamente
Nahrungsmittel was kommt vor allen
Dingen an
also ehrlich gesagt man kann sich wenig
vorstellen was man da nicht sieht also
da sind Schlafsäcke da ist Bettzeug da
sind Wasserflaschen da sind
lebensmittelkleidung ganz viel Schuhe
eben auch sanitäre Produkte also
Waschzeug Duschgel das fehlt ja alles
also man kann sich kaum also you name
mit man kann sich wenig vorstellen was
da nicht zu finden ist was uns die Leute
da vor Ort gesagt haben also was am
dringendsten gebraucht wird und was
wirklich fehlt jetzt in erster Linie
wirklich Lebensmittel also instant
Produkte die man einfach unkompliziert
aufwärmen kann die man mit heißem Wasser
eine warme Suppe also dass man muss sich
das ja vorstellen gerade hier in Lemberg
kommen Menschen an die haben zum Teil
Tage von also eine tagelange Odyssee
warten auf den Zug erstmal überhaupt zu
einem Bahnhof kommen dann haben die
stundenlange Zugreisen hinter sich die
haben da nichts zu essen zum Teil gehabt
oder so gut wie nichts das jetzt erstmal
brauchen die mal was Warmes im Bauch
also darum geht es ganz stark dann ist
ein ganz wichtiger Punkt der uns gesagt
wurde
Babynahrung also das klingt jetzt
irgendwie sehr sehr hart aber man sagte
uns viele Frauen auf der Flucht die
haben ihre Kinder gepackt und sind mit
dem was er am Leib hatten los die haben
auch aufgrund von Trauma und Schock sind
die nicht mehr in der Lage zu stillen
das heißt man braucht also dringend
Babynahrung das wurde uns gesagt und
eben auch medizinische Geschichten
gerade auch für die Armee brauchen die
Verbandszeug Krücken alles was
medizinische Produkte sind weil es daran
eben auch fehlt und gerade in den
umkämpften Orten wir haben ja gerade
gehört wie die Situation in rarkif ist
da werden halt all diese Dinge sehr
dringend benötigt auch
jetzt hast du die Lage der flüchtenden
schon erklärt die ankommen du hast auch
erklärt dass die Helfer ja auch Angst
haben dass es möglicherweise Angriffe
aus der Luft geben könnte deshalb du
hast es beschrieben dezentrale Lager vor
welchen Problemen stehen denn die Helfer
noch
ja also es sind ja zwei Arten von
Helfern das sind einmal wollen und
volontiert freiwillige Helfer die helfen
Umpacken das heißt in diesen Ortschaften
wo diese Lager sind da ist alles auf den
Beinen also da ist alles was was zu
packen kann ist in diesem Hallen wir
haben auch die Leute gefragt was machen
Sie denn sonst die haben ganz normale
Jobs und die sind jetzt in diesem Lager
und packen da an das ist wirkt wie ein
Ameisenhaufen alle Rennen durcheinander
ist funktioniert aber ziemlich gut und
ziemlich schnell auch wenn es auf den
ersten Blick nicht so aussieht das
zweite sind die Versorgung der Menschen
die jetzt hier in Lemberg eben mit
diesen Zügen ankommen da braucht es
natürlich eine
Betreuung im Sinne von dass man den
Leuten was zu essen gibt es gibt hier in
Lemberg sieben Anlaufstellen für
Flüchtlinge offiziell von der Stadt
eingerichtet das heißt die Leute kommen
vom Bahnhof dahin da kriegen die auch
wieder erstmal was zu essen dann werden
die da registriert können sich eintragen
in Listen dann wird werden die zum Teil
auch in private Unterkünfte vermittelt
zum Teil aber auch in Turnhallen Schulen
und sowas gebracht oder ihnen die
Adressen gegeben wo sie erst mal
unterkommen können so da sind natürlich
auch viele alte und kranke Leute dabei
unter den Flüchtlingen das heißt die
brauchen auch zum Teil eine medizinische
Betreuung es sind natürlich auch wir
haben gerade schon gehört in der Sendung
von Kindern traumatisierte Kinder auch
um die muss ich ja jemand kümmern das
sind ja Menschen die haben zum Teil
wirklich entsetzliches erlebt und haben
endlose Odysseen hinter sich
also damit ist deutlich dass allein wie
groß allein die Hilfsarbeit ist die
Hilfe die man leisten muss für die
Menschen die in Lemberg ankommen jetzt
hast du aber auch beschrieben wie alles
sortiert wird um ja auch Hilfstransporte
fertig zu machen aber wer kann denn
überhaupt noch versorgt werden wir haben
ja gerade ein Überblick gesehen wie es
in anderen Regionen aussieht manche
Städte werden von Westen und Osten
angegriffen einige fast umzingelt
kann denn überhaupt noch Hilfe nach
haarkiff nach Kiew etc gebracht werden
also nach Kiel funktioniert das soweit
ich das einschätzen kann im Moment noch
relativ gut da sind auch die Straßen
passierbar also da kommt man hin mit
Hilfsgütern zumindest ist das möglich es
wird sehr viel über Überzüge gemacht
also weniger über Autos mehr über Züge
weil das sicherer ist und dann ist aber
eben auch vor Ort wieder das Problem das
ist natürlich solange es keine
Feuerpause gibt sind natürlich auch
diejenigen die Hilfsmittel in eine Stadt
wie Harke versuchen reinzubringen
extremen Gefahren ausgesetzt
also eine komplizierte Situation und
alle Hände voll zu tun ganz herzlichen
Dank für die Schilderungen für die
Eindrücke und die Informationen Armin
Körper in Lemberg und für sie noch mal
der Hinweis wenn sie den Menschen helfen
wollen dann können Sie das tun den
Menschen in der Ukraine den Menschen die
auf der Flucht sind allen am besten geht
es eben mit Geldspenden über das
Aktionsbündnis Katastrophenhilfe zum
Beispiel iban.de
400-600-10-406 Wort 100 Stichwort ZDF
Nothilfe Ukraine und alle Infos auch
unter spenden.zdf.de oder im zdf-text
auf Seite 890
das war unser ZDF heute live zum Thema
Hilfe für die Menschen in der Ukraine
vielen Dank für Ihr Interesse einen
schönen Abend noch und bis bald tschüss